خمسه نصائح لخصتها صحيفه فاينانشيل تايمز
من بوكاست ماني كلينيك لتحسين اتخاذ
قراراتك الماليه في السنه الجديده يؤكد
التقرير ان البدايه بتهيئه نفسك نفسيا
للوصول الى الاهداف وتقول اننا ننجذب
ونجذب ما نفكر فيه معظم الاوقات التقرير
يشير الى ان تحديدا الهدف اسهل بكثير اذا
كان بامكانك وضع رؤيه اكبر للصوره اي ان
احنا نفسك وقتا لوضع خطه مبنيه بشكل افضل
على التدفق النقدي الشهري والاستهلاك
والنفقات المتراكمه وهناك برامج جدوله
تساعد على ذلك ايضا اعاده التفكير في
الميزانيه اي يجب ان تجد انظمه توفير او
السداد اكثر سهوله وكذلك ووضع حد للسحب او
الدفع اليومي على بطاقتك الائتمانيه ولابد
جدوله الديون خاصه عندما تجدها ترتفع دون
سداد شهري واخيرا الادخار واجب حدد جزءا
من الدخل كانه قسط شهري والتزم به واتمنى
لكم سنه ماليه مريحه